[Musique]
sur l'autoroute mais au pas de marche
il est midi et comme d'habitude depuis
le début du conflit les grévistes de la
cft utilisent leur outil de travail pour
manifester
il faut dire qu'ils peuvent compter sur
le soutien de leur direction qui ferment
opportunément les yeux sur cet usage
assez particulier des bus mosaïque
derrière les automobilistes englué
parfois plusieurs heures dans les
embouteillages hésite entre résignation
et exaspération
c'est quoi ces bus c'est les
manifestations de vieux mais on va pas
rester comme ça ils nous feront perdre
notre temps toute la journée
mais c'est grave ça fait plus de deux
heures goûter quelques heures plus tôt
une délégation était pourtant reçu par
le vice-président de martinique
transport louis boutrin les négociations
achoppent désormais sur un point
essentiel la reprise des salariés dans
une seule et même structure qu'on se
retrouve devant la situation suivante à
savoir qu'il n'y ait un transfert unique
vais en une structure unique second pour
appeler un maintien de l'unité
économique et sociale est manifestement
sur ça sent que martin transport ne sera
pas en position d'accepter
c'est à dire que l'idée du saucissonnage
sont toujours être dans le en tête
cette exigence d'une seule et même
entité est crucial pour les salariés qui
veulent ainsi voir transférer tous les
accords d'entreprise les contrats de
travail et les avantages salariaux mais
elle aussi crucial pour les très
puissants syndicats de la cité u qui
veulent ainsi préserver leur pouvoir
la réponse de martinique transport se
fait attendre en évoque la prochaine
réunion du conseil d'administration dont
personne ne connaît la date pour
éventuellement adopter cette position
il n'en fallait pas plus aux grévistes
pour reprendre les chemins de la
contestation le réveillon de noël
sera-t-il l'occasion d'une trêve
rien n'est moins sûr